[Music]
oh well uh
let's not get signals mixed there was
there was no convincing me to join the
franchise the
the answer would be yes it was more or
less
convincing him uh that he was making the
right choice and i think that's you know
those those meetings that we got to talk
about
things fast and and things life um
regardless of if
if it spawned any business between the
two of us i really had a great time just
talking
and and and he he puts it in his own
perspective i really enjoy
you know i'm grateful for for
his perspective on those meetings but it
was the same
for me we really is as two guys with
common interests getting to know each
other and talking about making something
worthwhile and uh
and from that you know jacob was was
born
[Music]
obviously the the mark of a good
professional is to to perform when
called upon but fast is a very um family
set in a very family setting so off
camera it really encourages togetherness
and it was like an experience like no
other everyone was extremely nice
first and foremost me playing a villain
that seemed like no one would give me a
chance but i don't i don't blame them i
mean you can't really
choose opportunity i i believe that
opportunity finds you and you just got
to be ready for it and
some of the you know the opportunity a
lot of the opportunities i've been
giving him to be a good guy and uh and
and vin and the fast franchise was brave
enough to take a chance on me as a bad
guy
whichever
all of the public is like well you can't
be a bad guy until they see
the movie and a lot of people thought
you know well you're you're just a wwe
superstar you can't do this and then you
know
i'll go get an up you know judd apatow
would be nice enough to give me a chance
to tell jokes
so then you get known as the joke
telling guy until you do something in
action and then you're okay maybe an
erection guy or but you're not a bad guy
and then you finally get a chance as a
bad guy so making the impossible
possible in this was easy
i got to be a bad guy
it was
man
it's surreal to find out that i would be
a toretto and dom's brother it's it's
all just so surreal it's tough to
conceptualize that i'd be invited into
the fast franchise in such a
spotlight um
this being my first movie and many folks
have dedicated 20 years of their lives
to the legacy of this and uh my
philosophy was just be a sponge keep
your mouth shut your ears open and
listen to the people that have
have crafted this story over the past 20
years and that that
really served me great as i there's a
lot of wise people
on the set of fast and i think it starts
with vin and he was instrumental in
giving me an opportunity and providing
me guidance through that opportunity and
i'm
grateful to him the rest of the cast and
crew for kind of helping me along on the
journey
it's it's the grass is greener
phenomenon you always get more excited
about the paints you can't use
and you you may have a bunch of paints
at your disposal a bunch of crayons at
your disposal but you always are excited
about the new colors the ones you get in
my 15 16 years in the wwe i spent a lot
of time as a good guy
and uh i've been given a lot of
opportunities
outside of wwe to
to be a general host or a good natured
figure which that's
i really work hard to try to be that at
my core but um that doesn't mean from a
creative set that i don't want to paint
with different paints and this what was
really exciting about this opportunity
is
fast taking a risk on on me going
against type and i was i was very very
happy with that i i really am thankful
for them taking a chance on me
i've been a fan of the franchise since
the very first one and
to be able to get an invite to join the
fast franchise was it's a life-changing
opportunity here i'm talking to you
across the world from each other but
we're all excited about this global box
office phenomenon that it always
delivers so i mean it was a very
unbelievable feeling to find out that
i'd be invited into the family
[Music]
i think what makes jacob deserving of
being in the in the fast franchise is
um
the the
excellent
perspective of we've seen dom toretto be
so focused on family
but throughout the 20-year history
besides his sister the family is family
that he's chosen those people that he
loves and those people that are close to
him but don't necessarily bear his
bloodline he now
looks as a perspective as a
as a father and also as a brother like a
blood brother and i i think that's a
that's a very interesting and curious
one that that adds
that that that makes the context of a
great movie in fast nine
actually the scene i was most excited to
shoot was um
the scene in the trailer in which
dom and jacob square off in the estate
in london
for multiple reasons one because i think
that face-off on the trailer looks
amazing too because it looks even better
in the movie when you see it in the
movie and three because when we actually
filmed they filmed an exterior shot with
about three million no with about seven
million dollars worth of cars and i'm a
car guy so i got to see some pretty
interesting rides so it kind of
it served a lot that that uh that scene
i specifically remember as being
very very good
the most difficult and dangerous is the
uh the brother vs brother confrontations
between jacob and dom and uh we just
we knew we had to bring that action to
another level uh because fast is known
for its action and especially
known for dom toretto's face off with
unsurmountable odds but this had to be
of a different nature this had to be
a fight between brothers and action
between brothers and a face-off between
equal opponents so those were definitely
the most demanding and the most
dangerous
i used to just move around from thing to
thing and always think about what was
next
uh i've really made a conscious effort
to enjoy
what's been done and and kind of sink
into the now and and
there are times on set where i'll just
look around and like what the f like
this is fast
and just take it all in for what it is
and uh
i think that's
that's how i relax by just understanding
what is really going on and not
taking this moment and trying to parlay
it into another moment there was a
previous question about what happens
when
your character and this character meet
and i'm not concerned with that i'm
concerned with
this because this is
something i've invested in and put my
heart and soul into and really hope the
world enjoys so being present and
relaxing and understanding what you've
done and being grateful for the chance
to be able to do it
that's a that's how i'd relax
the most interesting thing is the
the venus you don't see off-screen
incredibly generous and giving
and just wanting everybody to have fun
and have a good time and be connected to
this and he's so passionate about it and
he just sees from a
a perspective that's that's in rarefied
air there's not many folks who can see
from that lens and
man it's
that's the most interesting part the pa
and i think that's what keeps it
interesting
is a small handful of people that get to
see that and i was grateful to be one
i love the fact that i get to create for
a living and call it work and it's not
one day that goes by it's never lost on
me uh i'm a human being so sometimes i
wake up on the wrong side of the bed and
i'm
you know in a cruddy mood or whatever
but
at the end of the day i get to i get to
be creative
and call it work and uh
it's it's just not lost on me i'm i'm
very grateful for that
as far as
you know the the future goes i uh
i keep trying to expand my skill set and
expand that the tools that i can offer
a role or or different you know
different roles but i'll i'll know it
when i read it um the thing that's been
most effective for me is to
really understand story and that better
helps me understand my part in the story
so rather than chase a role like i would
like to do this please craft this for me
um
my process is more i'd like to read your
material
and see if i'm riveted by the story
because if i'm riveted by the story then
i'll enjoy being in it and i'll know
i'll know if it's within my skill set
to contribute to it so i i don't think
that's that's kind of why i'm you know
i've tried to do
family movies comedy action drama like i
don't i don't want to
shut any avenues off and i want to be
able to work with as many folks as i can
on as many different projects as i can
but i don't i don't necessarily know
what
my next choice would be because i
haven't read it yet
[Music]
selfishly it sucks to have to wait so
long to to you know something you've
invested in to
show the world but uh you know they say
patience is a virtue and this is a prime
example of that
my message is for people obviously to be
safe and responsible but
go to the movies and we're really taking
steps every day forward
to being a great opportunity to go to
the movies and enjoy we're talking
communal entertainment
where
strangers can enjoy
stories together
and i think that's been the magic and
the allure of the movies for over a
century now
and it's something that
that was taken from us in the last year
and
i'm
looking back on it i'm glad fast waited
i'm glad they waited for the theaters
because it's not just
the experience of like oh you gotta see
it on the big screen it's what a night
at the movies means to all of us
it means
going out it means
experiencing something with a group
like
it's it's all-encompassing and i think
yes fast is known for its action
but it's also since its inception been
incredibly diverse
it continues to be incredibly global it
films all across the world so people can
feel as if
they
it's their movie as well it does a great
job in attaching the world to what they
see on screen and it does so in such a
casual manner like it's always been the
ethos of fast so yes you're going to get
blockbuster action
but you're also going to get all those
subliminal things that fast is known for
that really
really give
even more of a reason for us to to go
back to the movies
i'm really really happy that we can
release it in taiwan and you guys get a
first peek at what the world is gonna
love and enjoy and i'm so excited and
you're so lucky you get to see the movie
first
i'm really really happy that we're
finally releasing f9 in theaters man get
ready for a hell of a ride because f9 is
an incredible movie thanks everybody
thanks for your time
you